hey this is really funny or this is
really weird to use one of my favorite
story segways Donald Trump is now
reportedly worried that there's this
insurgent movement of leftists on Fox
News that are taking it over and are
going to turn FoxNews against Donald
Trump and there's a really interesting
piece in The Daily Beast that says that
Trump has been having personal
conversations with his friends to the
extent that he has real friends about
how Fox anchors are treating him quote
unfairly and he's been asking people can
I really trust
Rupert Murdoch's kids to do what's best
for me and the gist of this is that
Rupert Murdoch is 88 years old his kids
are taking more and more of a role in
running different Murdoch businesses and
Trump is worried that Fox is going to
turn liberal and turn against him as a
result and he thinks he's already seeing
that as a result of some of the Fox News
anchors stopping short of parroting
Donald Trump's obvious lies a Trump is
also reportedly telling his senior staff
that he wants them appearing in more
places than just Fox I guess the idea is
if Fox isn't going to be 100%
deferential to them he's not going to
give them as much access to his staff
now the truth about Rupert Murdoch's
kids is that Lachlan Murdoch is now the
CEO of Fox Corporation he's a
conservative populist sort of in the
line of Tucker Carlson Rupert Murdoch
has another son named James who's more
liberal but he's not involved with the
network so the only things that really
happen on air that Trump could be
concerned about are that there is
sometimes like really soft opposition to
obvious lies from Trump or from the
people around him like sometimes Shep
Smith or Chris Wallace will say Trump
didn't tell the truth about X or Y or
Chris Wallace will you know confront a
Trump administration official and say
what you just said is not true but Trump
has been increasingly agitated by Fox's
coverage recent tweet series over a
weekend or Donald Trump said quote
watching Fox News weekend anchors is
worse than watching low ratings fake
news CNN or lyin Brian Williams remember
when he totally fabricated a war story
to make himself into a hero and he got
fired a very dishonest journalist and
the crew of degenerate Comcast NBC MSNBC
Trump haters who do whatever Brian and
Steve tell them to do like CNN NBC is
also way down in the ratings but Fox
News who failed in getting the very
boring dem debates is now loading up
with Democrats and even using fake
unsourced New York Times as a source of
information ask The Times what they paid
for the Boston Globe and what they sold
it for parenthetical parentheses lost
1.5 billion dollars or their old
headquarters building disaster or their
unfunded liability Fox News is changing
fast but they forgot the people who got
there so that's almost completely
unintelligible but let me explain what's
going on here because I've actually
explained this before Fox News is
right-wing they aren't going to stop
being right-wing but they're not married
to Trump and you might remember that
early in the 2016 Republican primary
back in 2015 Fox was not behind Donald
Trump early and in fact Fox News had
some very public opposition to trump and
public spats with Trump eventually Trump
kept gaining support Fox News came
around and Trump's been lucky enough to
have Fox News as the de facto propaganda
arm for his administration for most of
the last two-and-a-half years but Fox
News can be conservative and bail on
Trump and they may actually do that and
the scariest part of this is that I
predicted that if Trump breaks with Fox
News he will start promoting an even
crazier channel called Oh a N or oann
the one American news network and he has
actually started to push some of their
content out in the last couple of months
I got a few dozen tweets when Donald
Trump did this two months ago because
again I had said if Trump bails on Fox
he's going to oin Trump quoting and
responding to a report from oh a NN on
Twitter a couple of months ago and there
have been more examples of this as well
and this is like straight-up Alex Jones
Breitbart level propaganda this may be
what Donald Trump turns to if and when
he abandons Fox News the guys on tilt
he's hanging by a thread and an
impeachment inquiry come
with foxnews bailing on him if indeed
FoxNews does could send him completely
out of control in ways we've not even
seen yet I look forward to being along
for the ride but at the same time my
rational side recognizes this is really
bad for the United States of America in
ways we're gonna address a little bit
later on in today's program make sure
you're following the david pakman show
on instagram at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram as well at David
Pakman if you love learning new things
you probably want to check this out
the david pakman show today is sponsored
by Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video